で この経典で今までこのサマーディ瞑想の世界を最期のところまで説明いたしました
まあ一応経典の名前は Sunnata シューニャータという名前なんですけど
こちらでシューニャータとお釈迦様おっしゃっているのは
心の中でいろいろ概念がどんどん減っていくことなんですね
で 心にあるあらゆる思考
概念 認識っていうのは
いっぱいやればあるほど心が重いし
だからものがあるないということ自体も認識なんですね
ですから 空というのは客観的に存在するかないか
世の中は空ですか あるいは有ですかとかね
そんなのは知ったことじゃないんですよ
で 全て頭の中の概念なんですね
この龍樹ナーガルジュナが言ってる
このまあ相対的にものは存在しないとね
長いというものは まあ短いというものに相対的に存在するんであって
短いというものは長いというものに相対的に存在するんであって
別に独立した長いものというものはあるわけじゃないし
短いというものもないというふうな立場を取っちゃうんですね
うーん そうやって世の中で長いというものは存在するかと
という場合はありますよと言っちゃうと
我々の心の中で短いという概念が入っているんですね
短いものに比べて長いというし
長いものに比べて短いというし
そういうわけで独立していて
有という存在するというものはっていうのは実体としてはないんだいという話なんですけど
まあそういう話なんです
で 結局はそういうなんだかんだ言ってもこの認識の問題なんですね
長いと認識するか 短いと認識するかということで
だからものがあるかないかということをさえも
自分が認識しているかないかというぐらいのことなんですね
あってもなくても 自分が認識しないならば
もうそれで別に自分にとっては何の関係もないものになるんです
認識しなくても困りますよと
いろんなものがあるんだよって言ってもあまり意味がないんですよ
認識しないんだったら困ることでもなんでもないんだから
いろんなものがあって困りますよということは
それは自分が認識しているんだということでしょうしね
ですから 結局はシューニャっていうものは認識というところで成り立つもので
空というものはね ですから
お釈迦様は実践的に心の中であらゆるものを無制限にものを我々は認識すると
その分はものがあるということで
かなり煩わしい苦しみがある
そうすると 心からいろんなものを認識しない
しないことにする だから認識しないということは
それほど簡単なことではないんです
認識するっていうことは心の仕事ですから
ですから いろいろ工夫して訓練して
たくさんのものから一部選んで
これだけ徹底的に認識するっていう風に
認識するエネルギーをコントロールするんですね
だからいくつかのものを認識すると
他のものは知ら知らなくなる
その中からもさらに一つだけ見てみるとかね
そういうふうに まあかなり強引で修行しながら瞑想しながら
多数のものを認識することから
どんどん数を少なく少なくなっていって
最終的にはもう空というか
空ですね 赤ですね そういうものを認識しようとする
だから空と言えば空間と言えば
もう何も形も姿もないものなんですね
ですから 空間を認識するということになってしまう
他のものは何も認識しないと
これもかなりの修行で
だから空間を認識するとかなり空に近いんですね
で 心は空間のみ認識しているという
それから空間ということも物質だから
そこから空間を認識したがった自分の心のその状態を認識する
それは色無縁というし
で それで次にないという無ということを認識してみるんですね
いわゆる空間があったか
空間認識したっていうことは
心が空間認識したんだから
心がそういうふうに認識しなかったらね
それもないんではないかというね
ないということを認識しようと実践するんです
それがうまくいったら 7番目のサマーディ状態になってきて
さらにないということにして
心はほとんど この機能しない状態というかね
ある面で機能しない状態ですが
ある面でものすごい強力
徹底的な協力ついた状態なんですね
だから修行の結果頑張って得られる状態だからね
普通の弱い心っていうのは
あれやこれやなんだかんだでも認識しているんですね
強い心はそんな簡単にあれこれと認識しないんです
ですから 心は本当にすごい強いんですけど
心があるかないかという状態でもない
何も認識してないというかね
でもなんとなく心が動いている
それは 8番目の禅定状態で
それ以上は進むことは不可能なんですね
で 次にお釈迦様はヴィパッサナーの瞑想の方にあの
進んでいくんですね タッサ チア ナンダ ビッキノー イミナ ヴィハーレナ ヴィハラトー チャング マハ チッタング ナマティ
そこでこの最終的なこの
アナンジャというね サマーディを得て
それからまあまあちょっと散歩でもしようかなという気持ちになると
その比丘は ソーチャンカ メティ
それから歩くことにする
エワンマン チャンカマン タングナービッジャ ドーマナッサ パーパカ アクサラ ダンマ アンワッサ ヴィッサンティー
ティ イトヒタッタ サンパジャノーホーティ
そこで歩くときは 彼がこういうことをするんですね
ね アビッジャ欲とドーマナッサ
まあ怒りですね いわゆる悩みですね
欲と悩みの心ですね 欲と怒りの心
その 2つがパータカアクサラダンマ
不善なるものなんですね
自分が歩いている 歩いている間は
心の中で欲も生まれないよう
欲という不善が生まれないように
怒りという不善が生まれないようにと
いわゆるあらゆる情報が心に入るんですよ
歩いていると 今まで歩くことではなくて
1箇所で止まっても 厳密に心の訓練をしただけで
それからそんなものはもう終わり
修業しましたから 終わりまでやりましたから
サマーディ瞑想 それ以上はないんだから
まあそれからもうやることはないし
まあちょっと散歩でもしようかなと
で 散歩でもしている間では
もうその時は心のあらゆる情報が入るんですね
目から耳から その入る情報
情報が映っても 欲と怒りが入ってこないようにということで気をつけるんですね
欲と怒りが入らないようにと気をつける
アビッジャとドーマナッサが入らないように
アビッジャっていうのは
まあもう関係のない もう欲なんですね
ドーマナッサっていうのは
なんだかんだで嫌になるというね
気が立ったり 気持ち悪くなったりという
そういう心の状態なんですね
だから散歩をしながら
いろんなものを見ながら
音も入ったら音も聞いているし
体の感覚もあるし ちゃんと歩いているでしょうし
でも一つだけ気をつける
心の中にavijjāとdōmanassaが入らないようにということだけは気をつけるんですね
それだけに気づくsampajāniになるんですね
だから気づくということはそこに気づくんですね
見えないようにするんじゃなくて
見えても勝手に見えてもいいんだけど
見たんだからといって
見たものからavijjāとdōmanassaだけは生まれないようにと
そちらにサティが機能するんですね avijjā
とdōmanassaという不善が入らないようにガードするんです
見てはいけないではないんです
見ながら聞きながら味わいながら
でも心にあるガードをつけているんです avijjā
とdōmanassaが入らないようにと Tassa
ce ānanda bhikkhu no iminā vihārena viharato taṇhāya cittaṃ
namati. So tiṭṭhati.
ターナーヤ・チッタン
タッサ・チェー・アーナンダ・ビククノー・イミナー・ヴィハーレーナ・ヴィヒャルト
その比丘がそうやって修行している
歩きながら修行している
ヴィハーレーナ・ヴィヒャルトというのは
別に修行というよりも
そういう生き方をしている
それでターナーヤ・チッタン・ナマティ
止まってみようではないかというふうに心が変わるんですね
歩いていて じゃあ止まってみようと
エワンマン・ティッタンタン・ナービッジャ・ドーマナッサ・パーパカ・アクスラ・ダンマ・アンワッサ・ヴィッサンティーティ
イティ・タッタ・サンパジャナー・ホーティ
そこで歩いて歩いて それから止まるということにする
立っているということにするんですね
だから立っている時も
彼が一つだけ気をつけるんですね
立っていたというのは
音が入ったり いろんなことが入ったりします
でもその時もavijjāとdōmanassaというこの 2つの不善が心に入り込まないように
心の中に漏れないようにと
そこら辺にサティを使ってやうんですね
サティの一応プロテクターをかけておくんですね
サンパジャーンナというも
いわゆるそれだけ気をつけているんだということで
サティ サンパジャーンナはいつでも 2つを一緒に使う言葉ですけどね
タッサ・チェー・アーナンダ・ビククノー・イミナー・ヴィハーレーナ・ヴィヒャルト・ニサッジャーヤ・チッタン・ナマティ
それからこのようにやっていて
座ろうではないかと 座りたくなる
ソー・ニッシーダティ
座りたくなったら座ります
ソー エワンマン・ニシンナン・ナービッジャ・ドーマナッサ・パーパカ・アクスラ・ダンマ・アンワッサ・ヴィッサンティーティ
座るとき 座りたくなったら座るんだけど
一つだけ気をつけるんです
座っていても心の中にこの欲と怒りだけは入らないようにと
これももうかなりの訓練
前のサマーディ訓練とはものすごい質が違う訓練なんです
だからサマーディには智慧がそんなに必要じゃないんですけど
この場合はかなり鋭く智慧が働かないと
欲が入らないように 怒りが入らないようにということでね
タッサ・チェー・アーナンダ・ビククノー・イミナー・ヴィハーレーナ・ヴィヒャルト・サヤナーヤ・チッタン・ナマティ
それからもう横になろうではないかと思って
そう サヤティ それから横になる
歩いていて立ちたくなりました
立った 座りたくなりましたから座りました
それから横になりたくなりましたから
横になった 横になっても一つだけはすごく気をつける
体に触れる入る情報から
怒りと欲だけは入り込まないようにと気をつけるんですね
タッサ・チェー・アーナンダ・ビククノー・イミナー・ヴィハーレーナ・ヴィヒャルト・バーサーヤ・チッタン・ナマティ
それで何かしゃべりたくなる
何か話そうではないかと
ソ
ヤーヤンカタヒーナガッマポトゥッジャニカアナリアアナッタサンヒタナニッビダーヤナヴィラーヤナニロダーヤナウパサーヤナアビニャーヤナサンボダーヤナニッバ
ーナヤサンワッタティセイヤティーダンラージャカタチョーラカタマハマッタカタセーナカタバヤカタユッダカタアンナカタパーナカタワッタカタサイナカタマラカタ
ガンダカタニャーティカタヤーナカタガマカタニガマカタナガラカタジャナパダカタイッティカタスーラカタビシカーカタクンバッターナカタプッバペータカタナーナッ
タカタローカッカーイカサムドッカーイカイティバワーバワカタ
イティワーイティエーヴァルーピンカタンナカテッサーミーティイティタッタサンパジャーノホーティそこでその場合は簡単じゃないんですね
歩きたくなったら歩く
怒りと欲が心に入らないように気をつける
怒りと欲っていうのは外にあるものじゃないんですよ
そこら辺に欲があるんだ
そこら辺に怒りがあるんだというね
だったらしょうがないんですよ
体に入るんだから 物が見るとこちらで怒りか欲が生まれるんであって
そうならないように気を付ければいいんです
見るものに欲があるわけでも
怒りがあるわけでもないんです
聞くものに怒りがある
欲があるわけじゃないんです
こちらがそれを作りますからね
ですから 何を聞いてもこちらに怒りが生まれないようにとかなり気をつけてみる
何を聞いても欲が生まれないようにと
ものすごい厳重に気をつけてみるという修行なんですね
そこで立ったくなったら同じことで
座りたくなったらまた同じく気をつける
横になりたくなったら
また同じことで 入る情報については欲と怒りが生まれないようにと気をつけるというのは
このヴィパッサナーの修行法なんですね
そこで喋りたくなったらどうですかと
喋りたくなったら欲と怒りが生まれないように気をつけると言っちゃうと
ちょっと実践性が ちょっとお釈迦様にしてみればちょっと足らないんですね
具体性は ですから お釈迦様はきちんと具体性を作っておくんですね
哲学的に喋った方が分かりやすいかもしれませんですけど
お釈迦様にとっては哲学というよりも
すごい単純でものすごい具体的で
分かりやすく喋ってしまうんですね
そこでこのような話があるんですね
ヤーヤンカタヒーナ 品のない
ヒーナっていうのはもう品が低いというよりは
何て言いますか 卑しいというかね
かっこよくない話ですね
それからポートゥッジャ
これは読めないね ゲレスで
この話はゲレスで 非毒
非毒という言葉 ポオトゥッジャニカっていうのはこの非毒っていうことなんですね
いわゆる教育も何もない
そんな街ばたあっちこっちで喋ってる話っていうことでね
あまりもう教育のあるもう立派なもう人々は喋る話じゃないんですね
非毒 次の言葉は  凡俗に
凡俗に アナリヤ でアリア
アナリヤだが まあアリアっていうのは
おそらく仏教にはアリアの教えだと言いますから
やっぱりもうこれはもう出世間的な普通の人間のレベルをもう乗り越えている話ですからね
で アナリヤっていうのは
まあ日常茶飯事の話なんですね
日常の生活 世界の中でみんな言ってる話はもうアナリヤというね
アリアっていうのはもっとすごいレベル高い人で
いわゆる聖なるという意味でも訳できますけどね
仏教だったらアリエバーサ
アリアの話でアナリヤではありません
それからアナッタサンヒタ
あ こっちがちょっと一つ抜けて
聖者にふさわしくないっていうのはアナリヤなんですね
その次は利益を伴わない
そうすると何か言葉一つ抜けちゃったな
ゲレスベっていうのはヒーナーでしょ
ヒーナーガンマ  ポオトゥッジャニカっていうの
うん ヒーナー ヒーナーガンマ
ポオトゥッジャニカ ヒーナーはゲレスでガンマは非俗でしたっけ？そこで
ポオトゥッジャニカ  凡俗に
凡俗に アナリヤは聖者にふさわしくないという
まあ聖なる話ではないと
アナッタサンヒタは利益を伴わないものである
いわゆる何の役にも立たない話
それからニッビダーヤ
恩利のためにもならない
ニッビダっていうのは
まあ恩利であって 人の話を聞いて
どんどんもう気持ちが湧いてきて
何でもやりたくなって欲しくなったりするのは
それはもう普通の話で
仏教の話はもう物から離れる方向へ話すんですよ
あれも欲しいこれも欲しいという
わざわざと欲しがる気持ちを育てる話じゃないんですね
それは悪い話にしているんですね
ニッビダっていうのは
まあいいんじゃないかということで
もうもうもういらんという
この俗世間から離れたいという気持ちなんですね
ナ ヴィラーガーヤ ヴィラーガっていうのは離頓ですね
欲から離れる ニローダーヤ
滅尽にならない ニローダっていうのは
まあいわゆる煩悩の滅ですね
ナ ウパサマーヤ ウパサマーヤは寂静
いわゆる心の平安ですね
心は平安になること それからアヴィンニャーヤ
アヴィンニャーヤは承知ですね
優れた知恵 いわゆる解脱の知恵なんですね
この普通の知識よりもものすごい優れた知恵にならない話
ナ サンボーダーヤ 正しい
正しい悟りのためにならず
サンボーディっていうのは悟ることですね
ナ ニッバーナヤ 涅槃のためにもならずと
そういう言葉があるんですね
そういうことは喋りませんと
喋りたくなったら こういう言葉は喋りませんということに決めちゃうんだ
いわゆる品のない まあ俗的で
もう聖者にふさわしくない聖なる言葉でもないし
欲を減るではなくて どんどん欲を増やす話で
で そういうもう心は平安になるんじゃなくて
心はすごい混乱するものの話とかね
もう涅槃にではなくて
涅槃にものすごく反対のこと
話とか そういう話は絶対喋らないことに気をつける
言葉の場合 そこでそんな話って何なのかと
さらに明確にお釈迦様が例を出すんですね
それは有名な三十二種類の出家は喋ってはいけない話があるんですね
で これは出家の話で 出家した人々は大体三十二種類の言葉があります
それは喋れませんと 喋ってはいけないと禁止しているんです
それは何なのかと 一番目はラージャカタ
こちらは国王の話と書いてます
だからラージャカタって
ラージャっていうのは国王なんですけど
政治家っていうことなんですよ
だから昔はあの王様は
我々の王様はこういう人で
こういう人であると喋ること自体政治話なんですよ
隣の国は王はこんなもんでこんなもんだと言っちゃう
例えば隣の国の王がもう肉ばっかり食べたくて
もう女遊びばっかりやっているんだよと言っちゃうと
自分の国よりは隣の国があまり良くないってことになるでしょうに
それで政治的な話だから
インドの場合はたくさん国
国 隣 隣 隣ってあるんだから
もう結局あの人の政治が良くないなと思ったらこちら来てそこを取っちゃうでしょうに
ですから お釈迦様の時代では国王の話なんですけど
現代風に言えば これはもう政治の話なんですね
例えば自民党はこういうことで良くない
こういうことで良くない
こういうことで良くないとかうんうんと言って
また野党なんです 社民党でしたっけ
民主党 民主党はもうあの人はすごい立派な人だ
そう言っちゃえば 自動的に投票する人々の心が
じゃあ自民党にしないで民主党にしようということになるでしょうに
そこで政権が変わったりする可能性もある
ですから 政治話なんですね
この一番目 喋ってはいけないと
政治的な話は 二番目はチョーラカタ
盗賊の話 それもなぜ盗賊の話を喋ってはいけないんでしょうかね
これもすごい心が汚れちゃいますよ
で 人間好きなんですね
いろいろ映画を見ると
銀行強盗の映画やらね
列車強盗の映画やらいっぱいあるでしょうに
だから強盗は良くないのに
なんで映画になるんですかね
だから結局ものすごくするがすごく
いろんなことをして いろんな工夫して
もう銀行強盗をやっちゃったぞという
そこでみんな喜びを感じるんですね
ですから やっぱり人間というのは強盗の話は聞きたいんですよ
結局精神的に自分もそこに乗せられてるんですね
自分もその舞台の一部を演じてるんですよ
だから心は汚れるんです
必ずしも汚れる 強盗はもうどこかにいて
これぐらい盗んで たとえアリババなんとかという話を聞いたっても
もうもう強盗の死に物はアリババ盗んだんですけど
あ これでよかったよかったと思っちゃうんじゃないんですかね
その物語聞いても まあアリババじゃなくてアラジンですね
まあまあ アラジンがもうアリババと 四十人の盗賊ですか
四十人の盗賊の  sixty
アリババと 四十人の盗賊の話
それでアラジンがそれを全部もう盗っちゃうんですね
財産を取って もうみんな殺してあげてなんとかとするんでしょうしね
その話を聞いて ああ良かったかと思っちゃうでしょうね
良かったと思っちゃっても
アラジンが何やったんですかね
ところで 人の財産をね
アラジンでしたっけ？誰でしたっけ？わかりませんですけど
まあどうでもいいんですけど
そんな話でやっぱり良かったっていうことになるでしょう
ですから もうもう盗品というかね
もう人の財産も盗むことに自分も精神的には参加する
それで散々そういう話を聞かされちゃうと
自分でも何のことなく強盗になっちゃうんですよ
そういうことをするようになるんです
ですから その話は このお釈迦様が言った
この品のない もう心は汚れる
もう汚い もうものすごいいやらしい話ですから
やめろっていう  1番目は政治
2番目は盗賊の話 次に大臣のお話ですね
マハーマットの方 大臣のお話
で まあ同じ大臣の話の場合は政治と言えばいい政治でしょうし
管理の世界なんですね
で まあそういう話もみんなかなり好きなんですよ
だから映画の世界のそういうもの
いくらでもあるでしょうに
誰か誰かのもうもう FBI の誰かが CIA の誰かがなんとかなんとか
こういう風にあったとか
なんとかそういうストーリー
物語っていうのはいくらでもありますね
ですから 現代風に言えば政治話
王の話になっちゃうと小泉さんの話になるんですよ
彼が政治家だから 彼がもう全部政治取ってますから
その以下の話になってくると大臣の話なんですね
小泉さんも総理大臣 大臣だから
それも大臣の話っていうことじゃなくて
もう彼が総理大臣だから
もう昔は王の話なんですね
ですから 王の話はしないそうと思ったら
もう日本だったらもう総理も小泉さんの話もしない方がいいんです
大臣の話もしないんだそうと思ったら
管理職員の話やら 他の大臣かこの話やらもうしない方がいいんですね
次に マハーマットは大臣でセーナー方
セーナー方は軍隊の話
それからバーヤ方 恐怖の話って何ですかね
恐怖っていうのは恐ろしいと
だからホラー映画やらね
いくらでもあるでしょうね
それで人間の物語の中でも
お化けの話というより
ものすごく怯える 怖くなる話
話を聞いてものすごく怖くなるということは
もう考えてインパクト
そのインパクトなんですね
だから怖い話 もうよくテレビでもあるでしょうね
もうものすごい世にも珍しい怖い話だとか何とか言って
いろいろエフェクトをつけてエフェクトをつけて
まあ怖い話をする そこであの人間というのはすっごくどんどん鈍感になってくるんだから
あのもうテレビのこういう怖い話を見ると
まずもうドラマはもう一応録画してビデオクリップあるんですね
そこでそのままドラマとして流すんじゃなくて
もうもう最低の頭の悪いタレントという何人かがもうまず座っていて
その人々はまず世間話をする
ものすごい時間なくなっちゃうんですね
まあそれからあのビデオクリップを流す
そこでみんな驚いて怖くなったり
キャーキャーと言ったり
机の下に潜り込んだり
こうやったり それは演じるんですね
そこまでやらないと もうもうどこまで人間鈍感かと
恐怖の話知りたけ作りたければ
いきなり恐怖の映画を作ってボーンと放送すればいいでしょうに
ディレクターは誰々さんでもタイトルはなるやると言って
その時見る人々が本当に怖くなっちゃうと
作品は成功で なんだつまらないと思ったらまあそれで終わっちゃうしね
だからもうイメージの子供の
あの 何と言いますかね
まあイメージネーションの世界をね
じゃあ本にしようかなって
ローリングソンさんが
あの あの魔法の世界書いたでしょうね
それ世界中みんな読んでるんだから
これ抜群に成功でしょうね
何も説明も何もないし
もう何のことなく 本を開けた瞬間でもうそこに入りのめり込むようにしているんですよ
厳密に子供の心の心理を読まれているんだから
あの女の人に だからそれで何のことなく
それをもう今世紀のものすごい成功作品でしょうし
だからこれからそれも一つ昔話みたいに人間の中に残るだろうと思いますけどね
それぐらいすごいぴっしりできていて
それで説明する人も何人かが集めて
それで一緒によろこいたりしてくれる
じゃあこれも下手をいいところですよ
だからもう まあそれは能力のことでね
見る人々はね あまりにもあまりにももう頭が真っ白くて無知か
あるいは全くもうもう感覚器官麻痺されちゃって
脳細胞まで麻痺されているんだから
あそこまでやらないと
怖くなったり楽しくなったりしないかとかわからないんですね
あるいは作品を作る人々はもう世にも珍しいバカどもか
どちらかなんですよ ひとかけらも才能ないんだけど
もう金儲かりたくて作っているという
どちらかなんわからない
普通だったら能力ある人々は映画作ったりするんだから
それなりにいやもう見る人々は参ったぞということはね
なりますけどね まあとにかくそれはどうでもいいんですけど
まあ世の中ではいっぱい恐怖の話っていうのは
まあどんな世の中でも
どんな国でも どんな時代でも
どんな民族の中ではいっぱいあります
だから我々一般の人々から見れば
怖い話は聞きたい 怖い
怖くなりたい 怖くはなりたくないんだけど
怖い話は聞きたいという
ことがある だから聞いてどうなるかと
心怖くなるだけなんですね
それ 映え方 次にゆで方
戦争の話 まあそれもいくらでもありますね
あんな方 だから戦争の話を聞く時でも
必ずしも怒り殺戮を自分がもう心で賛成するんですよ
で 例えば戦争の映画なんかはね
もう見るたびにもうもう残酷に
あのまあドイツ軍がね
殺されたり もう壊された壊れたりすることをすごくもう賛成する
これでなんとか軍が勝って良かったとかね
二人ぐらいのアメリカ軍が軍人がいて
もう大量のもう四百六百人の
ドイツ軍隊があるところは全部爆破して帰る
いつでもそんなことあったわけじゃないんですけどね
で そういう話で それですごく喜びを感じるでしょう
だからもう戦争の話っていうのは
我々はわざと人殺しに参加させるんですよ
言った方 次にアンナカタ
食べ物の話 それから飲み物の話
アンナカタ パーナカタ
ワッタカタ ワッタカタ
衣服の話 サエナカタ 寝台でしたっけ？の話
まあサエナカタっていうのは寝台という意味ではなくて
やっぱり家具の話なんですよ
まあソファやら机やら
まあそういう まあ一般的にはまあ家具の話ですね
マーラカタ なんだこれ
ケマンじゃない  ケマン？日本ではないと思うんですけど
なんか花飾りとかのそういうのじゃないですか
字の通り訳すると花の紙と
ケは花ですね の紙ですから
紙に何か華やかに飾るとか
そういう意味じゃないかな
マーラーっていうのは一応首飾りのことで
あのマーラーっていうのは首
首にかけるアクセサリーですよ
ですから 結局はここで言うのはやっぱりアクセサリーの話なんですよ
あらゆるアクセサリーについて喋るとかね
とにかく世にある話の話のことを言って
アクセサリーについてあっても
いろいろ話 物語 エピソードいっぱいあるんでしょうに
ガンダカタになってくると
アクセサリーつけたところで
次にまあ香料でしょう
香りの話 ガンダカタ ニャーティカタ
親族の話 ヤーナカタ 乗り物の話
ガーナカタ 村の話 ニガマカタ
町の話 ナガラカタ 都の話でした
都の話 ジャナパダカタ
国のお話 イッティカタ
女性のお話 プリサカタ
イッティカタは女性のお話
次にあるのはスーラカタなんですけど
こちらパーリ語でプリサカタ落ちてますけど
日本訳には入ってますけど
男性の話 女性の話  じゃあやっぱりパーリ語でないんでしょ？プリサカタは
これ何とかより 何とか書いてるんじゃないんで
注に  そこにおいてどうのような使い方
なんとかなんとかテキストにはないと
だからこのCEという番号を振ってるテキストにはありましたと
とにかく数えて32だから
もう数えてみればそれを解決します
学者には難しいんですけど
一応リストは32に決まってるんです
ですから プリサカタで31
プリサカタで33だったらこれを落とした方がいいんです
だから数えてみましょう
それから まあとにかく女性の話が出てきて
もう男性の話 それから営業の話
いろいろ営業の話 次にヴィシカーカタ
ん？ 道路の話  道路の話
道路の話ってありますか？いっぱいある
本とか 旅行の話ですよ
シルクロードの話とか
どう行けばどんな街で何をして
どんな乗り物に乗ってとかね
だから今はないとっていうことは一つもないんですよ
これは人間喋るものだから
ずっと同じこと喋ってるんですよ
今もみんな喋ってるのと同じことなんですね
次に井戸端の話 クンバッターナカタ
だから今は井戸端に行けませんですけど
まあみんな余裕が暇があると
もうあっちこっち喫茶店に行ったりやって何やっていますか？という
それもうくだらない話しているだけでしょうね
昔は井戸端会議っていう言葉があった
うん だから昔はもう女性たちがね
水くみのところに行って
洗濯するところに行って
いろいろ洗濯終わるまで何か喋っていると
ですから まあそんな話で
今はそんなことやってないんだから
洗濯機でやってるんだから
我々もやってない やってないんやと言って威張ったっても
これはもうあまりもう外れで
もうその代わりにもうあらゆる所に喫茶店やりいっぱいあるんだからね
もうたまたまね 例えば何か飲みたくなって
こういう私は高級なところに行きませんだけどね
マクドナルドとかそういうところに行ってみたって
もう座るところはない
それぐらいいるんですよ
話して話も何時間でも
だから今もあるっていうことなんですね
井戸端話 次に先祖の話
先祖 先祖の話  先祖の話
これはあの先祖と日本訳しちゃうと
あの まあちょっと感覚感じが違いますけど
結局お化け幽霊の話なんです
だからどこかで人が自殺して
そちらが幽霊が出てくる出るんだとかね
この家でちょっと幽霊が出るんだ
そういう話ですよ それも先祖の話ですから
一応そういう幽霊心霊に関わる話なんです
ただ 自分の家で あの 50年前で何々さんが
おじい様がね ひいおじい様が何々さんでしたとか
そういう話は情報ですから
そういう意味ではないんです
ナーナって方 こちらの訳は
よもやま話  よもやま話
何ですかね  よもやま話って世間話
一般に世間話  なるほど
話題になってる話とか
まあいわゆるまあまあテーマを決めてなく
もう何かまあ喋ってるんだと思う
あれも喋ってこれも喋って
まあそのそういえばこれでああ言えばこれと
そういうもう何もただ喋ってるね
いわゆる目的なんとか
例えば旅の話だったらきちっとした目的だからね
じゃあ先生思いつきの話みたいにもなる
うん でしょうね 有名な話ですよ
雑談です  雑談ですね で
ローカカーイカ  これが世界説
世界説 はぁ これはちょっと研究はしているんですけど
まあこういう本なんかには
まあ亡くなった方々にはね
まあわからないんですけど
何かこの まあ特殊ないろいろ何か意味があるんですよ
で これはまあただ注釈書から訳してるんだから
研究論文参考してないと
ローカカーイカ サモンダッカーイカってひょっとしたらなんか今思い出せない
すごいその元号と言われと実際何か何かという
あの研究はありました
何か まあローカカーイカっていうのは一応まあ世界説と書いてますけど
あの このいわゆるもう世界のことなんですね
ヒマラヤはどれぐらい高いかとかね
あの富士山のもうどれぐらい
まあ海抜どれくらいですかとかね
で そういういわゆるこの地理学みたいな話ですよ
だから本当は地理学でもないんです
それは学校でやってるんだから
誰も喫茶店でそんな話をしませんよ
とにかくくだらん話ですよ
この間にアフリカに行ってきたんだけどね
実はですね こういうところがあって
ほとんど嘘ばっかり もう聞いた話やらもういい加減なことで
まあそれはどうでもいい
まあ地理的な話なんですね
時々よく案内してアドバイスまでするんだけど
いきなりあんた行ったこと？行ったことないという
行くんだったらこうしなさい
ああしなさいと偉そうなこと言うんですけどね
で 同じくもう海洋のね
海の話ですね 次にイティ・バワー・バワカタ
ありなしの話といったものでありなしの話なんですかね
有縁無縁とは違うんですか？ ただの雑談ですから
有縁無縁の雑談しないですよ
喫茶店では [笑い] 喫茶店しないですね
まあ一応何でも喫茶店でできる話なんですよ
ああいうことがあったとか
そうそうそう まあ私はこうだと思いますよと
私は来年は日本の経済状態は良くなると思います
いえ そう言ったっても私は思わないねとかね
私はあと五年足すと思いますよとかね
まあ今年は冬はあんまり寒くないんだから
私は思うのはもうすぐ春になって野菜の値段が上がりますよとかね
いい そんなことない 今どこからでも輸入してるんだから
そんな値段値上がりはしませんよと
またそうやって話すでしょう
それはありなしの話でしょうに
まあどうでもいいことで
一つはあるという 一つはないという
そういうありなしの話
だからありなしの話ではなくて
イティ・バワー・バワカタっていうのは訳これ訳が良くないんですよ
こうではないか こうではないかという話なんです
ああ言えばこう言う  ということではありません
違いますか 取り留めのない
こうじゃないか ああじゃないか
そう こうじゃないか ああじゃないかという風に
この論争する話です ティ・バ・イティ・エー・ルーパン・カタン・ナ・カテセル
そのような話はもうしない
あまりにもくだらなくて
品性なくてもうもうもうカッコ悪くて
もう下劣で もう喋れないと
もう涅槃にも関係ないし
心平安にすることにも関係ないし
知恵の知ですか 優れた知恵にも関係ないし
もうだから喋れないということで
何もない 何もない こちら 二十七なんですね
カイリッスのテリストには三十になってますけどね
二十七だからこれ男の話入れちゃうと 二十八になっちゃうし
イエ ルーパン カタン ナカテッサーミ
このような話は全くしないと
喋る時はかなり気をつける
だからその話喋ると心の中で欲と怒りが生まれてくるんですね
喋ったらいかんということじゃないんで
他の話喋ると欲と怒りがではなくて
知恵やらいろんなもうもう思想
思想のね 能力やらいろいろもう出てきますから
そういう話はするんですけど
そうやって欲と怒りばっかし
くだらなくて無意味で
その話はしませんというふうに
そこら辺で気をつける
その だから喋る場合も
論理は心の中で怒りと貪り
アヴィッジャとドーマナッサが生まれないように気をつけるということなんですね
でもそこで実践しにくいんですね
アヴィッジャとドーマナッサが生まれないように
どういう風に喋ればよろしいかということ
だからお釈迦様ははっきりとこのこの言葉
このような話だけはやめなさいと
話はやめなさい そうするとすごい簡単で実践しやすいんです
そこで喋る話はイティ タッタ サンパジャーノホーティ
ヤーチェコ アヤン アナンダ カタ アビ サッレーキカ チェトー ヴィワラ
ナ サッバーヤー エーカント ニッビダーヤ ヴィラーガヤ ニローダーヤ ウパサマーヤ アヴィンニャーヤ サンボーダ
ーヤ ニッバーナヤ サンワッタティ セーヤティーダン
で 喋る話はそれから出てくるんですね
アヤン カタ ヤーカタ アビ サッレーキカ
アビ サッレーキカっていうのはこの何意味数ですか
またアーナンダよ  またアーナンダよ
この話は削減のもの  削減のもの
手繰り取って減らすという
このアビ サッレーキカっていうのは
この やっぱり言語を辞書を引いてみると
削減という消するという意味にはなります
これ辞書の意味で もうその本当の意味ではありません
使っているのはまた違いますからね
アビサリ かなりの人間のね
まあいい加減な自由奔放な生き方をもうかなりコントロールされる
矯正される まあ矯正される話というね
いわゆるもうかなり注意させる話というかね
まあ自分を戒めるために
道徳的に立派な人間になるために
いろんなことを矯正 まあ矯正というかね
いろんなことを管理しなくちゃいけないんですね
ですから そのまあ 自由奔放で生きる話っていうと
反対にそうやっていろいろ矯正して
矯正して コントロールして
自分が道徳的な人間になるような関係の話
酒飲んではいけませんとか
麻薬は使ってはいけませんとかね
夜遊びは良くないとか
もう学校から帰るんだったらまっすぐ家に帰るべきですよとか
ゲームセンターに行ってはいけませんとかね
そういう風に人間 普通にやりたがっていることには
いくらか管理がつけるんですね
それでいろいろ自分の生き方に管理つけられて
道徳的になるような話
アビサリイッキタなんですね
それでアビサリイッキタっていうのは
やり過ぎという意味にも使っちゃいますよ
この戒律の場合はね よく出てくる言葉で
例えばかかとからどれぐらい衣は上に行くべきかっていうね
決まりっていうのは一応あります
それでちゃんと測ってみて
1ミリ下がってるんではないかと
あんた戒律を犯してるんだよと言って
これやり過ぎなんですね
それもアビサリイッキタって言うんですよ
かかとからはまあ 2センチですか
まあセンチとはインチかわからないんで
一応まあまあ これ測ってます
ミャンマーだったら で
とにかく地面に触れてはいけないんです
衣は で これで腰に巻くものはちょっと下にして
上に体に巻く衣はもっと上に行かなくちゃいけない
それで腰に巻く衣と上の衣の間も決まっているんです
どれぐらい歩くべきかとかね
で 基本的には地面に触れないように着なさいということで
だからそれどれぐらいかわからないんだったら
一応辛抱しちゃうと しょうがないんだから
で 辛抱されたところできちんと見て
これちょっともうちょっととかね
もうちょっと下がろうとかね
そんなことまで衣着る場合は言われると
これはやり過ぎなんですね
それで 5時中食べなさいと言っちゃうと
5時中っていうのは日本と違って
大体もう向こうは毎日太陽っていうのはほとんど同じ
出てくるんだからね じゃあ12時までやと言って
ちゃんともう時計持ってきて 11
時59分40 45秒 もう 55 秒
六七八 まあ終わり そんなことやるとね
で それはもうやり過ぎというかね
愚か者なことで あるところであるところで
日本でそういうことを私にやらせたんですけどね
自分たちがよく仏教を知っているんだと思って
時計まで持ってきて 秒読んでいて
私は一言葉言ってあげたので
それっきりはやらなかったんですけど
もう自分がアホでアホでアホでいいんだけど
それを新聞発表する必要ないでしょ
だからそれは頭が悪いということなんで
よく勉強して知ってるんだっていうことじゃなくて
だから戒律の守り方はこの戒律の専門家が知ってるんだから
戒律何なのか ブッダ何を教えたかというと
何も知らない人が知ってるわけじゃないでしょうね
そこで時計まで持ってきて
日を計算すると 親切に
みんなそういう親切な人ばっかりですからね
楽ですよ 生活は 親切なご飯食べるとか
時計見て待ってるんです
ちゃんと時間になったら行ってあげようと
だから私も自由だからね
言いたいことは何の遠慮もなく誰にも言います
それから その人は一生私と口をきかないと言ったっても
ありがとうございます
別に まあそういうこともまあ
ですから この阿鼻叫喚来たっていうことは
このすごい自分を管理するという意味なんですけど
またパーリ語でやりすぎという意味でも使ってるパーリ語なんです
だからこちらパーリ語を習っている苦労の方々がいますから
そういう意味でも使ってるんだっていうことを覚えておけば
先生意識して話しません
意識して  意識しているんです
よく余計な話はしないように
親だとか何かに注意されて
あなたはおしゃべりよって
余計な話をしないで 心に置いて意識してお話しなさいよってよく言われましたけど
小さい時に だからこの前の 30 何条を頭に置いて無駄のないようにしているかなと思って
うん だから同じことですけど
だから前の場合は否定形でこんなことをやるなよと
次に肯定で言うんで 何を喋ればいいかと
言葉の中でもやっぱり道徳的で
これこれやってあかん
これこれやってあかんということが出てきますね
そういうふうな肯定的で言うんですね
こういう話をしなさいよとね
それからチェート・ヴィワラナ・サッパーヤ
心の障害をはねるためにふさわしいもの
チェート・ヴィワラナ
心の障害ですね 心は成長しないんですね
成長しないのは心にいろいろ障害があるんですね
それでこの心の障害を何とかしてなくす話
例えば欲やらいけりゃ
それ心の障害だからね
なんとか欲をなくなるような話してくれる
美しいと美しいとみんな言ってるところにケチをつける話とかね
で そうやってこの 人間の心の障害をなんとかなくすような話ですね
チェート・ヴィワラナ・サッパーヤ
それにふさわしい話 エーカンタ・ニッビダーヤ
一考の怨理のために いわゆるすべての話はこの怨理
涅槃を狙ってるんですね
何を喋っても解脱涅槃することが最終目的にして喋らなくちゃいけないんです
それはエーカンタ・ニッビダーヤ
すべてエーカンタ あのいわゆるちゃんと目的ははっきりしているんです
喋るものはすべて 結局最後に涅槃解脱へと行かなくちゃいけない
怨理っていうのは涅槃ですからね
うん ヴィラーガーエ 人
ニルーダーエ  メス人ですね
それから寂静っていうのは平安
それから正智 優れた知恵
それから悟り 正しい悟り
それから涅槃 そういうものをを目指して向かって
一方的に まあどんな話したっても
最終的にはそこらに行かなくてはいけないんだと
話は そうでない話は全部心汚しちゃうんです
だからそこら辺は考えて喋りなさいと
自分喋ってることは本当に
あの 涅槃にね まあ人を導けるものでしょうかとかね
ですから 人が悪いこと悪いことしてあんたいいと思ってますか？とかね
悪いことしたらこういうこういうことになるんではないかとかね
それだけで止まっても
これ涅槃は入ってないんではないか
そんな話ではないんですよ
だからもうそれから延長線で涅槃というものあるんだからね
話はどこで切ってもいいんです
その延長線でちゃんと涅槃というものはなければいけませんと
それはどのような話かとまた説明するんですね
セイエティーダン アッピッチャカタ
どこでしたっけ 小欲の話
サントゥッティーカタ
知足の話 まあそれはその通りで
パウィウェーガカタ 穏理の話
で パウィウェーガカタと穏理の話っていうのは
やっぱりこのサバ世界にもうどのように生えるかっていう話ではなくてね
まあ静かなところで 物事から札付きから離れて
まあそういうふうに心穏やかにする
そういうふうな話なんですね
アサンサッガカタ 不交際の話と日本語だけで読むと意味がわかりますかね
で あのサンサッガっていうのは人間関係のっていう意味なんですよ
どうすれば人気者になるか
どうすればたくさん友達
友達が作られるか どうすれば自分の投票の数が増えるかとかね
だからこの人間関係を良くする良くする話はサンサッガカタなんですね
友達と仲良くする方法
パーティーでもうもう一人
なんて言いますか 一人ぼっちにならない方法とかね
パーティーで人気者になる方法とかね
まあ日本でもおそらくアメリカみたいにやるでしょうかな
わかりませんですけどね
まあこの高齢値の学生たちやらね
もう一年 一年一回はね
プロンと言うんですけど
すごいなんかバカでかいパーティーなんかやって
そこでもう自分が一人ぼっちにならない一生懸命なんですね
まあ日本では毎年だからね
忘年会なんかではね なんか隠し芸やらあれやこれやとかね
やっぱり人気者にならなくちゃあかんからね
それこそ人生は楽しいやと言いながら
それにものすごい苦労するんですよ
だから忘年会もそれなりに地獄の苦しみですけど
だって隠し芸やったり
いろんな踊りを見せたり
もうみんな楽しませ楽しませなくちゃいけないんだから
これ誰が楽しんで誰が楽しまってるとはやっぱりわからないんでしょうしね
みんな何かやらなくちゃあかんしね
だからそういう本やらね
いろんなものあるでしょうに
だからそういうのをサンサッガカタ
どうすれば世の中とたくさん友達を作って
たくさん仲間を作って
もうワイワイとやるかと人気者になるかという
そこでこのグループでみんながいないと寂しいという
これがもう病気ですよ
仏教から見れば もう誰かがいないと寂しくてもう楽しく楽しくないんだって言っても
いつでも何人かといつでもグループを組んで生活する
それ自体が世俗世間では素晴らしいことだと思ってますけど
仏教ではあれはもう病院行きやと
もう病気だと 一人で生活できないというならば
ですから この 何交際？不交際の話っていうのは
その話 一人になる話 いわゆる人間関係
人気者になる話ではなく
そちらの反対の話 例えば
もう今日は夜 私はこの本を読みたかったんだけど
これで友達が来てね で
いろいろもうもう何か用事があって
それでこの人のそれをやってあげたところで
もう私も混乱して もう全く読めなかったんだと
本当に人間というのはもうよく迷惑でしょうとか
そういう風な感じの話なんですね
そういえば なんかすごいもうわがままな話に聞こえるかもしれませんだけど
とにかく仕事をできなくなるんですよ
やらなくちゃいかんことをごちゃごちゃごちゃごちゃごちゃ
うろうろうろうろ回っちゃうと
気になるし その人に配慮しなくちゃいけないし
完璧に無視するわけにもいかない
無視しちゃうとすごい失礼でしょうし
だからやっぱり一人でいることが仏教は認めているんですよ
行儀悪いわけじゃないんだよ
人が来たらその人をちゃんともう認めなくちゃいけないし
その人の面倒を見てあげなくちゃいけないし
もうその人と話さなくちゃいけないし
人が部屋に来たって もう真に一言も喋らないで自分だけいちゃうと
これがね すごいもう気持ち悪いでしょうね
だから人が人と仲良くすると
こちらはもう礼儀正しいんだから一生懸命やるんだけど
それに乗せられて来たバカもなかなか出ていかないと
この人の人生は台無しなんですね
なるべく無駄な付き合いはしないように
それは皆様にはいいんだけど
佐伯にはもう付き合いしなさいしてはいけないと
一人で生活しなさいと
出家の場合 ですから もう普通の方々には
それはそれでどうでもいいんですけど
人気人気者だから食べてる人々もいるでしょうしね
で だからそういう人々は
その苦労はもうそれで儲かっているんだからね
それはしょうがないんですけど
出家の場合ね これは出家の話ですからね
出家の場合はもう付き合いはストップしなさいと
だから托鉢に出たってもよく出て慈悲経でも出てくるでしょ
クリースワナノギッドという言葉は
そこで家に囚われないなんとかと訳でしょ
ということは やっぱりこれも出家の話で
托鉢に行くでしょうし
だから同じ村で毎日毎日来ると
やっぱりあの家からこれもらう
この家からこれ もうすぐなんとなく気持ちっていうのはもう出来上がっちゃうでしょうね
向こうもこちら知ってて
こちら向こう知っててとかね
やっぱりそれでも束縛してはいけないんだと
その家のことを自分に訪せてくる家のことを心配で心配になっちゃうこと
もう束縛が生まれているんですね
ですから 何でしたっけ
このパーリ語では アサンサッガカタ
アサンサッガっていうのは交わるっていうことなんですね
交わることは良くない
だから交わらない方へ話す
だから人といろんな交わりがあったら
いかに面倒くさくても良くないかと
動物にしても同じことですよ
もう勝手に えらい迷惑というか
面倒くさいというかね
動物も面倒 本当にもうもうこちらが別に好きでなくても
動物の方がこちらのことをもうもう気に入ってくれると
もう向こう喋りもできませんだからね
好き勝手にもう迷惑すります
私は大学で勉強した時はもう一人で生活していたんですけどね
だから野生のリスが来て
すごい仲良くはしてくれたんですけど
ずっともう大学終わる
卒業するまで でもそちらが勝手に来て
私は一生懸命いろいろ論文書いてて
これはもう構いませんね
向こう側 やらせませんね
あっち引っ張るは これ引っ張るは
噛むはもう鉛筆をカチャカチャカチャカチャと噛んだりして
これ引っ張って持って行って
どこか屋根の上にも置いたりするって
もう大変なんです そこで自分が思い存分遊んで
そこで帰っちゃう もう野生だから
ほんでずっと徹夜してもう勉強したりしてた場合は
もうもう次の日はもう寝たりするでしょうし
動物はもう午前中仕事して夜寝るんだから
もう起きてきて こちらもうヘタヘタ寝たいんですけど
もう寝られないんですよ
来てここら辺噛んじゃうと
あの鋭い歯で これ痛いでしょうに
とにかくもう鼻やらここも噛むんですね
もう痛いし だから起きなくちゃいかん
それで遊んであげなくちゃいかんし
まあエサもそれなりには一応あげますけどね
餌の時間は餌の時間で
その時間は我々もいつでも食べ物ないんだから
それを知っていて その時間ではちゃんと来る
あるいは来なくても呼べば来ます
名前付けてやったんだから
名前呼んだらもうサッと来て自分の食べる分を持って帰りますけど
それからの時間なんですね
まあ大変です だから動物にしたってしても
そうやっても交わっちゃうと
結構まあ邪魔といえば邪魔なんですよ
だから人間はそれだけで生きてるんだから
人間それ上 自分のレベルを高くしようということじゃないですよ
毎日楽しくて みんなと仲良くして
ニコニコと笑って 何か食べて寝て
それだけの人生だから
それはそれで交わることはいいかもしれませんだけど
何かもうちょっと普通の人間より何かいいことをしようと思っちゃうと
これがもうできないんですよ
どうしても人々のレベルに合わせなくちゃいかないんですね
だから人々のレベルを乗り越えようと思うんだったら
もう別に一人で生活するしか方法がない
次にヴィリヤアランダカタ
不交際の方針 精進努力の話
シーラカタ 戒の話 サマーディカタ
サマーディの話 パンニャーカタ
智慧の話 そこら辺は一応分かりますね
解脱の話 ヴィムッティカタ
解脱の話 それからヴィムッティニャーナダッサナカタ
解脱知見の話 ある解脱をする
解脱の世界についてしゃべる
これ解脱した人々の生き方についてしゃべる
解脱しているなんとか人がこういうこういうことで
こういうこういう風に生きて
そういう解脱知見っていうのはそういうものなんですね
イティ エワ ルーピン カタン カテッサーミ
このような話だったら話しましょうと決めます
イティ タッタ サンパジャーノホーティ
そこで彼がサティを実践してみるんですね
喋る時に だから私にももうものすごい質問されたでしょうね
この喋る時はどうします？喋る時はどうします？ヴィパッサナーの場合はね
でもまあ答えはこういう答えなんですけど
これはもうもうそこそこなんとかヴィパッサナーみたいなものをやってる人にね
もう喋る時はこうしなさいというのは教えられませんしね
お釈迦さんは一応答えを出してます
喋る場合はこういう風に喋りますよと
ここでちょっと 1日 2 3
時間のお休みできてヴィパッサナーやり方
じゃあこれから家に帰ってやるぞとかね
今教えているのはちょっとした実況紹介するぐらいのことでね
それで喋る時はどうしますか？と言っても
やっぱりまあ私はその時はまあやめなさいと
それしか方法ないんですけどね
ちゃんとヴィパッサナーらしいヴィパッサナーやるともう喋る場合はこういう風にっていうことになるんですね
禁止されている言葉をやめて喋ってくださいという言葉を喋るようにする
それ喋りたくなった場合なんです
で 次なんでしょうかね
次に彼にヴィタッカチッタンナマティ
何か考える考える考えることに何か考えたくなる
もう考えたくなったら考えちゃいますよ
考える時はどうしますか？と
ヨー
メーヴィタッカヒーナガンマポートゥージャニカアナリアアナッタサンヒタナニッビダーヤナヴィラーガヤナニローダーヤナウパサマーヤナアヴィンニャーヤナサンボーダーヤナニッバーナヤサンワッタティ
そこで考えたくなったら考える
でもこの品のないもう即席で
もう欲 怒り 憎しみ そんなものばっかり出てくる
聖者にふさわしくない
前と同じリストなんですね
何の利益もない 涅槃解脱心の平安には何の利益もない
そういう考え方はしませんと
どんな考え方ですかね
カーマヴィタッコ 欲のことを考える
あの人は綺麗だ あの花は綺麗だとか
あの食べ物はおいしいんだとかね
欲のことを考える カーマヴィタッコ
マーパダヴィタッカ 怒りのね
あの人に騙されちゃって
本当に今度来たらもう何とかしてやるぞとかね
それで怒りのことを考えるとかね
私はここまでその人に親切してあげたのに
全く不親切な人ではないかと考えちゃって
怒りが出てくる だからとにかく何考えたっていいんだけど
考えることから怒りか欲が出てくるか来ないかっていうのを気をつけるんですね
で ヴィヒンサーヴィタッコ
人に害を与える思考なんですね
まあそういうのは考えないことにする
エーチャコイメヤーナダヴィタッカ
もしあるヴィタルカが
あのー 何でしたっけ？考え方がありア
聖者にふさわしいニーヤーニカ
解脱に導かれる ニヤーンティタッカラッササッマドッカッカーヤ
実行すれば苦しみをなくす方向へ向かう
なくす方向へ まあ道進む
そのような思考を考える
とにかく思考っていうのは考えてから行動するんだから
この普通の人間の妄想のことよりも
仏教ではヴィタッカだから
ちゃんと論理的な思考のことを言ってるんですよ
だから現代人よりはちょっとマシな人間でしたからね
現代人がよくまで妄想しかせかしてないし
ですからもう思考っていうのはないんですよ
だから何か質問したら答えられない
これはどうすればいいかと言ったって
変に答えが出てくるのに
えーとですねとか そこで
もうもう蹴飛ばしそうになっちゃうんです
いいやと あんたの話は考え方と
もうもうだから瞬時に考えられませんだから
だから一日中妄想だからね
だからそれは病気なの
精神的な病気で それを治してから瞑想した方が一番やりやすいし
だから妄想するなかれと言ったっても
思考するなかれっていうことじゃないんですよ
だから我々は行動するのはまず考えて行動しますよ
ですから その思考っていうのはすごく綺麗で
まあこういう風にこういう風にしましょうと
三時にこれして 三時半にこういうことをして
これはこういうふうにして
だからそれはみんなに言う前に頭で
じゃあこの場合はね まずこれこうやって考えるでしょうね
そうやって論理的な思考のことを言ってるんです
ですから 論理的な思考の場合は
一応実行というものはね
考えただけというんだったら何の意味もないでしょうに
だから実行すれば必ず解脱の涅槃に導かれる思考はするんだと
それはどんな思考かというと
ネッカムビタクコ 欲から離れる思考
アッビャーパードビタクコ
慈しみに関係ある思考
それからアヴィヒンサ
人に害を与えない いわゆる人を助けてあげるような協力するような思考ですね
そのような思考はビタッケッサーミで考えて考えましょうと
考えるときは イディタッタサンパジャノーホーティ
そこでヴィパッサナーの実践方法をお釈迦様は完璧に教えているんです
歩く 立つ 座る 横になる時
どういう風にするかと
あのやる別にずっと気をつけるだけのことで
アビッジャーとリアパーダが入らないように
だから普通に生きている
普通に生活していて生きてるんだけど
ものすごく心で気をつけてるんですね
アビッジャーとドーマナッサだけは生まれないようにと
それがヴィパッサナーの瞑想法なんです
普通に料理を作って 掃除もして
もう枯れ葉なんか全部全部まとめて
それはちょっと燃やしたりとかね
もう普通いろんなことをやって生活はする
でも何やっても秒単位で自分の心の中でアビッジャーとドーマナッサが生まれないようにということなんですね
だからすごい格好いい品のある修行方法なんです
表面的にはまるっきりわからない
ただ道路の掃除しているんだと
ただ雑巾かけてるんだよとかね
大根の皮剥いてるだよとかね
そんなもんで普通に生活している
でも厳密にこちらでアビッジャーとドーマナッサが出てこないように気をつけると
それでその人は喋らなくちゃいけないでしょうね
喋る場合はこういうことをして考えないことあかんで
その時は もう何て言いますか
ネッカムビタッカ アッビャーパードビカッタ
アヴィヒンサビタッカだけ考える
だから喋ることも考えることも
他の行動も 全部完全に一人の人の命
一日中 24時間の命を全部まとめてやるんです
それ以外別にやることはないんだから
だからこれ漏れてるんだよっていうことはないんだ
それだけで完璧なヴィパッサナーのフルセットなんです
それに付け加えようと思って
色々説明やら色々出ますでしょ
それで全部崩れちゃうんです
付け加える人はもう 個体な完全なものを壊して壊して
もうバラバラにして壊すだけ
付け加えることできない
だからほんのちょっとほんのちょっと教えたらやっぱりみんな困っちゃうんです
何考えればよろしいかとかね
妄想はどうしようかとかね
で 妄想はやめる どうしようかというと
やめるだけのことでしょうに
で だからもう何回何回も同じことを妄想だけはやめてくださいと
私の責任じゃないんだから
別に で どうすればやめますかと
何か方法あるかというと
もう二度と口が聞きたくない
その質問をすると で 一回その質問されて口を聞きたくないのに
これ一回じゃないんですよ
何回も同じ質問するんですよ
だから結局は私の修行になって終わっちゃうんですね
それなのにドーマナッサが生まれないように
で まあ考える時はそういう風に考えるのと
喋る時もね まあ喋る時はどうやってヴィパッサナーできますかね
実況中継できる 喋ってます
喋ってます 実況中継しながらヴィパッサナーできませんよとかね
それは当たり前できませんだからだったら喋ること
喋るとかヴィパッサナーやめなさいということしかないし
で 真剣にヴィパッサナーする場合は
喋る時は自分の言葉に気をつける
これは有益な言葉か無益な言葉かとかね
欲が増えるか減るものかとかね
怒りが増える話か減る話かとかね
そこだけだったら本当にヴィパッサナー修行やったら
みんなの話し方っていうのは抜群にものすごい素晴らしいものになるんですよ
だから本当にヴィパッサナー実践しているかないかとか
これは一日 二日 三日でわかるんですよ
みんな周りでも あんたすごいいいことを言ってるんではないかとかね
かなり周りの社会に役に立ちますよ
だから昨日も言ったんですけど
すっごく明るくなって
活発的になって 人の役に立つ人物になりまして
何か喋ったってすごい
これがすごい大事なことだとよく言ってくれた
言ってくれたんだというね
そういう風になる人間にはなるはずなんですけどね
では そこで一応ヴィパッサナーの修行法で
それでやり方 実践の辺はそこら辺で終わる
それから進む時は次にノーステップでどうやってチェックするかということは次に出てくるんです
今日はそこら辺で終了します
で 次に残ってる人は本当にかなり 1週間
2週間厳密にヴィパッサナー瞑想して
次の説法聞いちゃうとびっくりするほどの意味がわかるはずなんです
ただ読んだったら ああそうということでわかるんです
だからこれはもうパーリお釈迦様の教えのね
いつでもそんな誰が読んでもわかるんですよ
それで舞い上がったらもうえらい勘違いで
お釈迦様は本当は出世間的な超説法したことを言ってるんです
それはもう実践しない限りは気づかない
だからって誰にもわからなく喋ったって何の意味もないんだから
もうどれが読んだってわかるようにお話をする
でも真理のみ 誰にもわかる
わかるようにと言って
お釈迦様は自分のレベルダウンすることを全然しません
わかるようには言うんですけど
真理だけ厳密に語ってます
だけど そのところはね
大変なところです